what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy chapter of one
piece and thank Oda we actually get the
on-screen continuation of the Blackbeard
and law fight in a totally unexpected
bombshell of Epic Proportions near the
end so make sure to stay tuned for that
shall the parking with it and smash that
like button with no mercy be a smashing
pirate king rather than passing Orochi
and make this the video you subscribe if
you haven't and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one piece chapter
reviews and updates and now without
further Ado let's jump into It spoilers
and all this chapter is called egghead's
research stratum and the cover page is
crazy we actually see auger and cools on
of the Blackbeard Pirates as they're
called on the ship with pudding
kidnapped so yes we have been expecting
this but so crazy to finally see kuzan
there and present it as kuson of the
Blackbeard Pirates I cannot overstate
how crazy it is that Blackbeard has a
dude who could have potentially become
Fleet Admiral on his this crew working
under him Oda may make it an interesting
fight between law and Blackbeard but
again there's just no way I see
Blackbeard Pirates having real trouble
beating law and his crew the best law
can hope for is to escape in my view but
anyways we start strong and the panel
composition is amazing here we see
Blackbeard on stronger the Pegasus
nearing law and preparing an attack he
says there's no Escape so don't bother
running and even the narrator is hyping
it up big time by saying this is a
battle that shakes the world law gives
some orders like Versace and penguin to
get in the sea and provide cover then he
unleashes room amputate separating
stronger's upper and lower body
Blackbeard is surprised saying no one
told him he had the power to do that and
he wonders if he's using an awakened
technique and in my view Blackbeard
definitely has to be ready for surprises
here since law is one of the dudes who
beat yonko big mom so Awakening and
trickiness should definitely have been
factored in I almost feel like
Blackbeard is rushing in overconfident
here in contrast to his past Master
planning but it'll probably be all right
since as I said I don't see Law's crew
pulling out the W here Blackbeard starts
using his Quake powers and some of Law's
men comment on how the shock waves are
too intense meanwhile shot she jumps
into the water illustrates how great he
is in the water and even unleashes a
water attack to set off some apple bombs
before they can harm his crew this will
be an interesting direction as we may
get great swimmers like Chachi who
definitely looks like a fish man going
up against all these devil fruit users
who can't swim shachi then brags saying
it's a big mistake to underestimate us
when we grew up in the harsh cold Waters
of the North Blue I like to see this
confidence in bravado from Law's side
it's definitely been missing in the past
they even say that the Blackbeard
Pirates don't stand a chance against
them in a sea Battle since the hard
Pirates can just sink the Blackbeard
Pirates ship I like the Strategic plan
and how they're not just trying to out
fight them respected a hard Pirates
definitely doing better than I thought
off the bat but again I'm still not
hopeful in their Victory I think this is
just Oda making the battle interesting
before Blackbeard Pirates ultimately win
Beppo warns Jean Bart about auger
sniping and the latter steps in to
protect law as law uses Croom now this
was part of his Awakening where he uses
a special moving and shifting room that
surrounds his sword and allows it to
grow insanely long and do other crazy
stuff we should be worried by this
because we know that using his awakened
Powers quickly drains lost stamina as he
himself admitted thus if law hopes to
win he knows he's gotta do it quick now
by the way if auger is here kuzan could
be too since they were both together
with pudding in the cover story however
the Blackbeard Pirates may be so
confident about this matchup that they
didn't even bother to get his help for
this one auger Praises Bart for his
bodyguard skills so that's nice again
heart Pirates are putting on a good show
for now law penetrates Blackbeard with
his sword and uses shock Willey as he
did with yonko big mom it hurt her and
of course it hurts Blackbeard who
doesn't know what's happening it's
Illustrated similarly to when it
happened to Big mom with blood shooting
from all directions but Blackbeard is
legendary for his ability to take pain
and it's even been said that he's a
monster and his body is odd even after
taking attacks from Whitebeard and
sengoku during the Paramount War he was
fine when Shanks came he's one who feels
pain and expresses that but so far he
never seems to be affected by it for
long so this will be interesting to see
if law can actually do serious damage
auger is not worried but just says this
is what happens when he charges in
poorly prepared auger warps to
Blackbeard and asks him if he wants to
return to the ship but Blackbeard tells
him not to be an idiot and they finish
what they start he even laughs but he is
sweating law is definitely a beast with
that move that can hurt so many monster
level Pirates props to Blackbeard though
for not backing down now that the dye is
cast he's now retreating until it's over
and before you know he's on the ground
with law law asks him if all his
officers have crude powers and that it
must be difficult carrying around so
many anchors because fruit users just
sink in the sea however Blackbeard just
says the weakness is well worth the
trade-off and this is just my thoughts
here but someone like kuzan can just
freeze the water making sure people
don't fall into it if he really needed
to we jump to laws crew with their
Submarine underwater trying to sink
Blackbeard's ship this under the sea
experts versus devil fruit anchors
strategy is pretty great it's even
commented who knew they were so strong
underwater this fight has definitely
given me more respect for the hard
pirates in two chapters than I got
during all of wano but to be fair they
were separated from the sea then we've
jumped to where pudding is being held in
a prison one of the guards says that
they may be taking a pounding now but
he's coughing the hard Pirates will be
history soon since Blackbeard is the
strongest around pudding says big mom is
going to make them eat their words if
she's still alive and I definitely think
she is personally but it's interesting
how things turned out as they mentioned
that they are fighting big mom's killer
now meaning law we then jump back to the
epic fight and this appears to be where
the Tilt happens although it may be too
soon to say Blackbeard will immediately
win now both of these characters are not
yet confirmed to be Conker's hockey
users but we get a clash that's similar
to when we see Conker's hockey users
Clash we have a point of contact and
black line shooting out not sure 100
what to make of this and I suppose it
could be Blackbeard using the Tremor
Tremor fruit and its shock waves but
I've been saying for a while that I
definitely think Blackbeard has Conker's
hockey let me know what you think of
this panel in the comments if anything
can hold back lost Powers it would be
powerful hockey then while The Clash
itself makes it seem like they're tied
Blackbeard starts to use black Vortex
which looks really bad for law like
really bad black Vortex is Blackbeard's
Ace in the Hole no pun intended he used
it against Ace and boa and succeeded in
sucking them in and then nullifying
their powers this could be the end for
law but since law hasn't even used
puncture will a yet his finisher against
big mom I feel like it may not be over
just yet it would be better to see law
unleash all he's got and then still have
Blackbeard win to show just how strong
He Is We then jump to another huge name
Fleet Admiral sakazuki the Marines hear
that Blackbeard and law have made
contact on winner Island and sakazuki
mentions that they are forced to wait
again like on wano and it's so
frustrating being Fleet Admiral you know
when he finally moves is gonna be big
and then we return to Egghead which is
great but I am so invested in the
Blackbeard stuff right now that I just
want to get back to that but to be fair
there is some great stuff here including
the bombshell that's going to be dropped
so we'll get the that soon enough for
some reason the pacifista stopped when
they changed ages Bonnie used her powers
to make her younger jinbei younger and
Chopper and Luffy way older Luffy is
shown as a 70 year old and we're told
this is a glimpse into a possible future
interesting I assume what's being said
is that Luffy might turn out to be a
jacked 70 year old like GARP instead of
this withered out 70 year old it
definitely raises some interesting
questions about her powers for instance
how would 39 year old Luffy look as cool
as we think or less cool because
Bonnie's Powers don't necessarily give
you the best possible future Luffy as we
may expect has less sympathy for Bonnie
and her father pacifista thing but
Chopper and jimbe are more understanding
which I guess makes sense since Luffy
didn't even know he had a dad until
relatively recently so he has none of
those feelings Bonnie is working through
jinbei presents an interesting
perspective saying that Kuma didn't have
a good reputation before it said he was
a tyrannical King that was deposed by
other people and forced to become a
pirate when he was caught by the Navy
his ties to the revolutionaries came to
light and they gave him the life
sentence vegapunk took an interest in
him due to his physical prowess so he
was offered to roam the Seas as a
warlord on the condition that he could
become a specimen for body modification
and cloning definitely some useful
background information here Bonnie can't
get though why anyone would knowingly
agree to become a Mindless cyborg since
it is as bad as a death sentence she
says this as she's using what appears to
be a lightsaber of sorts Bonnie adds
that her dad was no Tyrant he hated the
government and would never submit to
them she assumes they forced him to
accept the procedures somehow Luffy even
though he's 70 still Marvels at how
awesome the so-called beam saber is
Bonnie continues saying vegapunk is a
murderer Bonnie also drops that Kuma
belongs to a very special race which
means that she's half that special race
which makes it even more possible that
she joined and This Crew filled with
different kinds of people hashtag Bonnie
for straw hat I also must say this
futuristic outfit is looking great on
her in the meantime the other straw hats
are being taken up to the research
stratum which is right above the clouds
we're told Luffy and the others are in
the fabrication stratum below them the
gang is excited when they see the ground
is like Sky Island here but surprisingly
Zoro and Brook stay on the ship after
zoro's words about how Vega Punk is
gonna listen I think most of us expected
him to go see him but that's not how it
goes here they get to the entrance of
the main lab and are told to switch to
appropriate attire before they enter
thus we got the whole crew rocking the
futuristic outfits now and my favorite
part of course is that we get to enjoy
seeing Nami and Robin in them as well we
then jump to punk one AKA Daft Punk and
he says the problem with being a genius
is that you can see your own future
coming too a voice asks what are you
talking about vegapunk vegapunk responds
I think I'll be dead soon and the voice
says don't kid about something like that
like a punk continues I just wanted you
to know about this dragon and quote the
narrator asks how are these two
connected and that is the end of this
insane chapter so now dragon is brought
back into the story and vegapunk is
looking like an undercover revolutionary
which may be why cp0 is going after him
in the first place that also makes me
think perhaps Kuma isn't really a
Mindless cyborg or at least his memories
and personality might be retrievable
because you know a revolutionary
wouldn't want to hurt Kuma but he may
make it look like that to our world
government whatever happens I'm loving
one piece right now it's so exciting for
the beginning of an arc and really makes
me feel like we are speeding up towards
an ending now although I'm hoping it'll
last for years more now channel the
pirate king with it and smash that like
button if you enjoyed the review and
want to keep them coming be a smashing
pirate king rather than passing Orochi
make this the video you subscribe if you
haven't hit that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece chapter reviews
and updates let me know your thoughts on
this epic chapter in the comments below
so much to discuss with this one until
the next chapter or video drops feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on Dragon and hour-long video on Shanks
on all seven yonko and much more link to
that is in the description and on screen
right now thanks for watching and until
next time see ya Space Cowboys